today we are going to kind of build up
on something that I've done in the
previous class because I see some people
stayed over in the previous class the
rookies is that what it's called roots
rookies rookies we did some issue we
talked about the issues of King safety
and security and how to easily get
punished we saw a bunch of games none of
which was more than longer than 10 moves
so that was really unpleasant for some
of the poor opponents that lost those
games now we're going to see better
opposition in those game you have a lot
of like very almost almost beginner
level players now we can have two very
strong players we have again between two
very very strong players the player with
the white pieces is Emmanuel Lasker he
was a world champion for 27 years I
think that makes him pretty decent
player and his opponent is also a
grandmaster from what used to be
Yugoslavia now it's defined as them as
Vasya appears and he is if some of you
know opening there's a ph opening PES
defense named after this gentleman so in
this game we will see what happened
white and black played a very aggressive
opening and Sicilian defense and at one
time black decided that he's going to
take over
however he forgot something very
important before you want to take over
the position you better make sure that
your king is safe and that the
opponent's pieces have no easy access to
your king or else so let's take a look
at this game and I'm going to make
comments and there'll be all kinds of
interesting sad variations sometimes the
variations that were left behind the
scenes are no less interesting than the
game itself so you have e4 c5 Knight f3
knight c6 okay a normal Sicilian we know
that black can play d6 e 6 or 936 or all
kinds of side moves as well d4 the main
line white wants to win the d4 square
which he before was completely black so
must take take and again this opening is
so flexible that many things that that
you want to play you can play you can
play a six and you can play g6 and you
can play the move in the game Knight f6
wendy6 is possible that's flexible but
possible so he plays nine of six
attacking the pawn and of course white
defends upon here again you have several
choices you can play east six or d6 are
the most common ones one thing that you
have to worry about in some position
that this specific structure and again I
want you to understand it for every line
in the Sicilian one one of whites idea
is to take this night and to go E 5
because the poor Knight will have no
good place to go to so he plays the move
d6 stopping this idea that's one of the
ideas another one is to play six which
makes d5 stronger again White has many
many moves at his disposal you can play
Bishop e2 like in the game Bishop e3
Bishop g5 is another very good move very
active move f4 ok he plays here once
again Black has a bunch of moves
he can play g6 or you can play East 6
like the game or you can play e5 even
ePHI business is a very aggressive line
he decides to play six and we have now a
very normal Sicilian very one of the
more common Sicilians it's called
describing again Sicilian it's a place
in Holland I'm not gonna repeat it again
so castles a six so far normal white
castles King side very normal
a six is a very useful movement in those
Sicilians you don't let the opponent
control this square for one of your
Knights sometimes and of course you are
hoping that maybe later on at some stage
you'll be able to play b5 because in
this opening white controls the center
and the King side and black tries to
fight his way in the center and
definitely has an advantage on the Queen
side
okay so Bishop e3 the last undeveloped
minor piece comes to the game very very
nicely Queen c7 again an acceptable move
the queen is very good especially if at
some point you want to push the B pawn
to b5 this night will need extra
protection as well so that's not not
illogical and white plays f4 that is a
very ignore all those arrows for a
moment this is a very logical move f4 is
a move that makes sense without f4
white cannot really claim any advantage
in the game
sometimes I see this game and people
play a move like f3
or Bishop f3 and you are really gonna
miss the control of that Center because
those two pawns make sure that all those
squares right here are well-protected
you need to exert some pressure so f4 is
a very very logical move now in the game
black played the move Knight a5 he
immediately starts action he moves a
piece the second time in the opening for
the second time how many of you have
heard the expression don't move the same
piece twice in the opening how many
times have you heard up how many of you
have heard that before
some of you those who haven't have just
now don't move the same piece twice
unless you absolutely have to why you
have other things that you need to do
for example if black would have played
the move let's say Bishop e7 and then
follow it up with castling we would have
a very normal routine Sicilian that I
have seen maybe a thousand times in my
life and you can see tons scores of
games in the database so that would have
been sensible but black says okay I want
action and I want it now
right here so I thought that's very
interesting
I'm cancelled my opponent isn't castle
what's more it's going to take him at
least two moves to Castle because his
Bishop is still stuck on e7 I mean it's
gonna be really crazy if black is going
to try to castle that side where I can
just send all my forces to attack him so
okay what should I do
and after some thinking he came up with
the most aggressive move anybody want to
guess if you want to participate it's
great you can just raise your hand I
don't want anybody calling out moves
because it's gonna be like a zoo so if
you're white and again I'm not giving
you enough time to think I mean if you
gave you let's say 15 minutes maybe you
can say okay I want to play this
maneuver that move but right here right
now what do you think by intuition white
wants to play yes well I would love to
play the move b3 except I have a real
serious problem my queen and c7 is
attacking this Knight here if I push the
pond to b3 who is defending this Knight
right don't want to lose the knight
right anybody in this class that is
really fond of giving away their pieces
for no reason please see me after the
class we're gonna play the game called
water $4 I'm gonna give you a quarter
and you're giving me a dollar we could
play this game all day and if you think
this is like something that you would
never do don't do it in chess either
it's just not logical we don't want to
give gifts we are willing to give
something the same way we would use
money if we bite something in the store
if it's a candy or a toy
we don't mind we get something in return
but to just give away pieces like it's
Christmas no Martin okay it's a
reasonable move developing the Queen
connecting the rooks not letting black
play 94 but after Queen d3 I'm guessing
that black intended to play the move b5
remember a6 before b5 supporting the
advance of this bishop and also the
knight is going to insist on jumping to
this square again notice one thing white
if he can help it he doesn't want to
worry about the Queen side who is the
boss of the Queen side black the black
player is boss of the Queen side we
control the center and the King side we
would love to have as many open lines
and files on our King side because
that's what we have more space that's
where our pieces have more access to so
yes very good you see when when you see
your face or knock your back you come up
with very good ideas keep it up
so f5 that excellent choice very very
good white says well normally maybe I'll
be reluctant to play this move but
because the knight on c6 normally
there's a knight on c6 remember the
knight was here let's move to hear that
Knight can maybe go into this beautiful
square on e5 and maybe you don't really
want to allow it but now that the knight
already moved sideways by the hope of
coming here let's start by opening up
the lines so now black has a dilemma now
I can tell you something little bit a
little bit maybe over your head so don't
don't be too scared but nowadays players
will consider playing the move e5 c5 it
looks like a crazy move because it gives
away the square forever for white and it
also make this pawn become a backward
pawn upon that's really hard to advance
but you gain a tempo over the knight you
kick it from the center square and later
on you're gonna fight to try to play the
D you'll fight for the d5 square you're
going to
but pieces in a way that protected and
again I don't want to go into too many
analysis because otherwise we'll be here
for hours
however block decided to just continue
with his plan night see for mind you the
player with the black pieces just like
the play with white PC is a grandmaster
he's holding the highest just idle he is
not some beginner or player from the
first group that comes here who is
really making his first step such as he
is a very experienced player but as we
can see sometimes even they make really
goofy moves so he looked at this
position said well the knight is
attacking my bishop on III the knight is
attacking my pawn on b2 which will not
only if I get to take this porn let's
say not only would my queen be attacked
but my knight on c3 will be attacked by
the screen this is going to be a good a
disaster so I don't really know if I if
I move on Bishop back to c1 I'm gonna be
on developing and my knight on d4 is
gonna look really funny maybe Queen b6
so what's my basically forced move yes
again I don't really want to allow
Knight takes beat you with a tempo right
if I go Queen d3 is gonna play Knight
takes pawn attacking my queen I have to
move my queen again right no so if I
don't want to lose time I have to accept
rate and then yes what do you think take
it take the mic right absolutely Bishop
takes Knight again sometimes it's forced
so he took it and took it okay so we had
to give up a good Bishop but we are
gaining time f5 with a gain of tempo you
play Knight c4 I took it you took back
now it's my move again what would you do
here is white very again I'm not giving
you a lot of time to think because we
want things to move so it's kind of just
by fear I only see like one one hand up
don't be afraid say that you're white in
this position you say okay I have more
control of the center in the King side
in order to maximize the control I want
to have as many open files and diagonals
and squares for my pieces how do I
achieve that yes yes
well the question is do I want to trade
Queens White is thinking to where the
problem is that I don't want to trade
Queens because why I am castle my king
is already safe the black king is stuck
in the center and it's not like even if
you castle the next move it's my move is
white and you're still gonna have to
take at least two moves to castle move
the bishop to e7 and then castle I'm
gonna try to use this time to make life
as hard as possible for you before you
get safe if I create Queens I don't
think that black is gonna be in real
danger so again use your imagination
what do we need to do the first move is
not very flashy it's not really like wow
what an amazing move I never would have
thought about it it's like okay why did
I play f5 what was the purpose I wanted
to have open files for my rook so I'm
gonna reveal it myself
of course she just took here and again
black should have been very very
cautious about what's happening to his
King side he was very very very
unconscious that's not a good idea
he should have definitely developed his
bishop and taken the pawn maybe he
thought well if I take with my bishop
this point is going to be isolated and
weak and okay maybe it is a little bit
because of what you did but when you
take back with the pawn the way that he
did watch what happened he took with a
pawn big mistake big question mark you
can already see that the arrows reveal
the weakness of the black King so now
what to do it's kind of given the hint
is give him I want everybody to take
like pay close attention and again it's
one of those things where it's gonna be
very hard for you to calculate and again
I'm not giving you time to think so I'm
not being fair but again I want you to
really understand what happened here
white is so much better developed than
black yes three minor pieces out black
is only one the Queen is here developed
but it's not really doing anything it's
more vulnerable than it is it it's more
far away from the defense my queen is
just ready to pounce and have another
rook that once the Queen moves is ready
to come and help so what to do in this
position let's hear from who haven't we
heard before all the way in the back
I would love to do it but what stands in
my way yeah I don't feel like giving my
queen away right I'm willing to win my
queen away give my queen away if I have
a checkmate or something like this not
not just for free but the fact that this
night is annoying us and preventing the
Queen from giving Chuck might lead it to
the idea yes my glasses not an
unreasonable move but Bishop g5 Bishop
e7 immediately right I'm immediately
going to defend my knight and try to
castle right so again it feels like
Bishop g5 Bishop e7 and black is like
just in time yes all the way there you
exactly yes I know I I'm not that bad at
math I know the rook is worth five and
yes I know the knight is only worth
three it's like you give five five
dollar bill and you get three back
didn't you just say not to do that yes I
said not to do that unless what did I
say unless you get something for it you
get something for it and boy do you get
something for it here took the night
well if you don't take the night if you
don't take the brook then you just lost
you night for nothing and believe me
that's gonna be a win so he decides to
take it he has no practical choice and
now that the knife is removed everybody
has a thumbs up that that means that
Queen to h5 check now let's start
looking where should we move the King
not that many good squares I can go to
e7 d7 or d8 let's take a look in the
game he went King to d8 which seems to
be the fate the safest if you would have
played King to let's say d7 which is
probably the worst then check Bishop e7
Knight f5 notice how beautiful this is
not really a sacrifice because this pawn
is pinned if you take my knight I'm
going to take your Queen bye-bye
game over and in the meantime my queen
is hitting this what a disaster you can
play rook to e8 Knight takes d6 again a
beautiful move because the King is
overloaded he is defending the rook and
that pawn and notice that the bishop
cannot move its pinned just a
catastrophe after I don't know what to
play I really honestly don't know what
to play here this white is just rushing
completely crushing he wins his material
back in the blocking is traveling do you
think that the blocking is going to stay
alive in this game everybody is nodding
no and everybody is right so instead
what if you would have played let's say
King to e7 then what then comes another
interesting sacrifice Knight f5 check
been everything we're willing to pay
everything it costs as long as we have
enough be enough guys to made the King
pond takes other night comes check and
Wow that King is just where is he gonna
go King here because where else can you
go I'm really I'm really really said if
you go to d8 then my bishop is gonna
check you here and you have to go back
if you go to you six Queenie a check is
just gonna be checkmate on the next move
you block with the bishop and I take it
it's mate horrible and when you go here
then Queen and I can also play night
here winning your queen by the way
Knight here is a four but this is even
better check and is this fun only if
you're white right only if you white so
yeah we see that the King went on a nice
trip from which he is not coming back
so after this he decided to go King d8
okay so now this is the safest he didn't
get checked and you can get sacrificed
on yet and now they have a question now
I played another very very strong move
which I'm going to show you Queen f7 the
Queen goes right into the game again now
the Queen is simp is threatening a
simple fork and black allowed it why did
he allow it let's say why why didn't he
even bother to defend this poor pawn in
the game he went Bishop d7 and he took
the pawn took the rock and I'll show you
very quickly how it ended after Bishop
h6 again he's trying to be tricky and
hit the bishop and also win the knight
and the queen is attacked by the rock so
if you take the rook I'm going to take
here and then take the knight so he said
okay no problem
you're gonna win two pieces for my rook
I've been my two piece for your rook but
check Queen takes Queen takes work and
after check King h1 and bye-bye game
bye-bye game you're down are
look for a binder piece plus two pawns
plus your King is suffering a lot so
block is a grandmaster he knows that
loss care he's not gonna miss this and
he says I resign
that's it but let me show you also why
didn't he protect the pawn why didn't
you go Bishop e7 that looks such a good
mood like such a great move because once
again we take advantage of the fact that
this poor pawn is pinned the Queen is
opposite that Queen and we played
neither five threatening Queen takes a7
checkmate
if you go Queen c7 to defend against it
I'm gonna go Knight a force surprise I'm
about to go Bishop b6 and when you Queen
where are you gonna go rukia fate that's
the attacking my queen my queen will
move away no problem and after the King
starts running away Bishop e6 Queen here
Queen check here nice Chuck here mate
good game again we see a tremendous
fantastic attack against the poor King
just no hope
look at this Queen side what tells the
story of the game the rook in the corner
that did absolutely nothing the bishop
in the corner the bishop that hasn't
been developed didn't even play one move
this rook was always ready to play if it
was needed but as it turns out he wasn't
even needed that's how easy it was okay
I have one more game to show you which
I'm going to do more faster than I
intended and it's not a very long game
as you will see and after that I'm gonna
let you play a little bit this is again
again again between two grandmasters the
Grandmaster would White is robot she
also has an opening named after him is a
very good Grandmaster his opponent is
even stronger bent Larsen one of the
best grandmasters of the past
he beat Fischer in some important
torrent Bobby Fischer and was one of the
serious candidates for the World
Championship watch what happened again
watch how aggressive he played and white
wasn't cautious he got punished Knight
f3 thought and v e4
what a tremendous resource Dwight wants
to just go and completely hunt
the black king from the second move but
Larson is just not is not a weak player
he knows what he's doing so he took
Knight g5 and now the idea is that white
really wants to play the MU he doesn't
really want to regain the pawn as much
as he wants to play the move d3 and
tempt black to take again so that the
bishop will come out and then thanks to
this weakness the whole black structure
is going to look really funny so black
says okay forget about that you can take
my pawn be my guest
so again he's trying to do this III
excellent just when white head really
hopes that maybe black will take in his
Bishop will get developed and if not
then the pawn will take and the bishop
will get developed here black says nah
you want my pawn take it back but don't
get the structure that attacks me
sorry so he took back had to take with
the bishop because has to protect the
knight attacked by the queen knight c6
developing Queen check now this just
shows that white was too disappointed by
the fact that he didn't get an attacking
position so he tries to create down it
create one anyways but black is just
saying you're not gonna make me like
that I'm sorry g6 Queen f3 okay white is
really really anxious to made black
right he wants to play Queen f7 mate so
Larson said you know what
not today nope and now if white was
really smart he would just trade Queens
and at least they'll play an ending yeah
of course I'd rather be black than white
because the white pieces looked really
funny and some of them not even
developed but he decides to move in
Queen is Queen this is just too much now
black is going to show that he is much
better 97
the knight is coming to f5 the knight is
gonna come here at the right time so
Knight c3 h6 94 Queen f7 a beautiful
little square for the kid for the Queen
you cannot really hurt my Queen there
I'm protecting and I'm keeping an eye on
the file on the diagonals I'm in good
shape once again white
a chance to play a quiet game but he was
really afraid he was worried that od5 is
coming when the night comes when the
knight moves away then d4 forking two
pizzas so again black is better here but
white should just move his pieces away
should move the bishop he should move
the knight and get ready for this
instead he was very ambitious he decided
to go here when I first saw this move I
thought of myself well that's a very
serious move not only is white
threatening to take the pawn on c7 and
win a rock because of the fork but I'm
also threatening to go Knight d6 Jack
and after pawn takes my other Knight
will jump and I have a family fork a
Royal fork attacking the king and the
Queen how is blood going to defend
against that is he really forced to go
King d8 now and really mess up his King
situation never to be able to castle
Larsen said nope Knight f5 first step
I'm stopping the check on g6 forget
about that and I'm attacking your queen
if you're gonna take my pawn here and
I'm gonna attack you with my King you
have no time to take the rock because
your queen is under attack
alright so he moved the Queen to f3 now
he played another very strong move he is
defending the pawn on c7 in the best way
that he can pawn d5 notice how beautiful
the knight now cannot take on c7 -
there's a queen on f7 defending it and
now the knife is hit if the poor Knight
is moving is gonna move then we're gonna
play a six and this night we'll have to
go back but not here because he's gonna
lose a piece so he's gonna have to go
all the way to the rim do you think this
is fun for white now so he decides okay
I'm gonna go for it but again when you
play someone like Larson just going for
it it's not going to be enough you
better have something up your sleeve but
he didn't
he played Knight f6 check I said okay
takes check King here Knight takes a it
for a moment white is up a rook and upon
for a knight looks really awesome also
the black king is stuck in the center
and it looks like wow this is fantastic
even if I end up losing my knight in the
corner the king is in such a mess and my
King as white is going to go
to safety somewhere life is not that bad
but you know who's moving is it's black
knee movement Larsen said if you thought
that I'm gonna just go night hunting or
something I'm not let's see if maybe one
of you can come up with the next move
for black he takes a little imagination
to think how do I undone a little
material my king might look a little
funny but the white king is also a
little funny he hasn't Castle yet and
he's not not quite ready to Castle maybe
he's ready to Castle queenside now so I
better act and I better start moving yes
yes it's possible it's not a terrible
move but I mean I can just push my pole
and defend it right I can block the
check with my pawn and attack your
bishop that might make things out of a
mess right messy right maybe you have to
start sacrificing more I have a
relatively simple move if you think
about it it's not that hard to see that
really gives me a chance to attack
things yes very interesting because
indeed white wants to attack this pawn
with Jack right wants to take the pawn
with a check that could be a little
inconvenient right this second okay but
how do we do it what is the best way to
stop that Chuck and at the same time get
an attack moving yes to take the bishop
well I don't wanna lose my Queen notice
that my queen is not protective if you
move my deny T here I'm gonna go Queen
takes Queen check oops right yeah so
I'll show you the movement let's see if
we can all understand what's going on
efore very very good the pawn is
attacking the Queen preventing it from
taking the d5 pawn with check and in the
same spirit we can see that our Queen
the black Queen has opened a beautiful
diagonal to the b2 square
well the Queen is being attacked what
can you do he decided to take it and
then Queen takes I should mention that
if he went Queen d1 then I would
eliminate this Bishop before it goes to
defend and after here I would play Queen
takes pawn and whatever you do move your
rook Bishop before Jack
you can already tell that black is
attacking with great force after this
check and the poor King is traveling and
now you can take my queen but I'm gonna
play Bishop takes pawn III checkmate
impressive right I've cleaned Queen
sacrifice so why probably saw that and
he said you know what this is really bad
news let's take this pawn and now black
snap the pawn and beat you again
attacking the rook and again the other
moves but bishop before check is coming
with great force so he decided to bring
his queen back now watch black from this
point on he is down in exchange but
watch what he does first of all bye-bye
bishop before this Bishop if I gave a
check with this Bishop then this maybe
this bishop is gonna block nope I want
to take this bishop I also want to open
the F farm watch why takes takes Queen
check beautiful little check even better
than the bishop check and now what to do
in this position all my choices are
miserable if I block with the Queen I'm
gonna lose my rook with a check if I go
King II - I'm gonna go right into this
line of the bishop and Bishop g4 check
is gonna take my queen so I have to play
King after only move yes because you in
check my queen you see my queen is
checking your King no time yet he's
gonna do it but you notice that this not
now so King after you and again black
plays a marvelous move yes his pawn is
threatened here with Chuck but he thinks
okay it's one check I'm not gonna die
because of one check you don't have
enough forces to beat me just yet in the
meantime I'm gonna hit first so he says
wow the King is lined up on an open file
I really love to have my rook come here
but right now there's a bishop here so
should I just defend this pawn and spend
time or should I just do something with
my bishop and start attacking he says
forget about this pawn who cares about
this pawn Bishop c5 already with a
threat of Queen III checkmate so white
said okay Queen takes pawn check
and black said Bishop d7 you had one
check good for you I'm happy for you
now I'm defending my stuff now Rukia
fate is coming but even worse Queen
takes III checkmate is coming what a
disaster so in the game he went Bishop
to d3 cutting off the Queen's attack on
the pond or e3 but it's too late when
you look at the position you just sense
Black has a queen a bishop a rock is
coming to the game the White King has no
good escapes but you just have to do it
properly so what did he do step one
Queen comes in Queen d2 check so he
plays I think that he actually resigned
here right because I think let me see
yeah because where are you going to go
you have no place to go to in this
position let's see bit if you hide here
then I'm going to go check and mate if
you go up I'm going to go Queen takes
here check and that's mate if you go
King up here which seems to be the best
possibility again I'm gonna go check and
after here I'm gonna play high we can
look we will look but let's start with
this this again and the only move you
can block with your Queen and I'm gonna
take it with checkmate so the King is
hunted all the way through you asked me
about King f1 that's a good question
after King f1 what do you think I will
play hello
and mate mate is coming very sore all
you can put your queen on f5 but I
really don't think that this is solving
your problem right I'm gonna take it and
I'm attacking you
so Whitehead to resign Oh guys okay guys
thank you very much and I want to see
you guys find an opponent and play some
chess